[Music]
little our reform means empowering the
people who actually do the work to make
decisions about how the work is done but
it also means that how reform is done
usually matters more than whether reform
is done let me give you a simple example
more than ninety nine percent of
america's teachers are usually rated as
effective even in places where most
children don't seem to be learning what
do we do about this over the last five
six years Washington and lots of state
to adopt a new policy requiring the
principal's observe teachers regularly
using test scores to evaluate teachers
you know what's happened in most of
those places 97 or 98 the center
features are still rated effector what's
going on principals don't have any
incentive to pick a fight with their
teachers nobody really wants to get
tough minded but what matters most is
how this stuff at the end of the day
gets done that's the key we need to
focus less on grand policy solution and
morale and asking what does it take to
make these policies actually work in
real schools for real case to learn more
about my take on the promise of little
our reform check the links in the
description below also let us know what
other topics you'd like a TI scholars to
cover in 60 seconds
[Music]